- AAH!
[squelch]
- HI.
[lock clicks]
I WANT THE TRUTH, STEVE,
'CAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE FAKING IT.
- NO, I'M NOT.
I SWEAR TO GOD.
- YOU KNOW,
WHEN I WAS IN THE JUNGLE,
I DID A FEW THINGS
I WASN'T VERY PROUD OF.
TECHNICALLY, STEVEN,
I'M A WAR CRIMINAL.
- GOTTA ROLL.
NO, WOODY,
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- YOU KNOW, THIS WAS BANNED
BY THE GENEVA CONVENTION.
COOTCHY-COOTCHY,
WOOTCHY-COOTCHY.
[baby talk]
COOTCHY.
YOU'RE A TOUGH
SON OF A BITCH, STEVE.
I WOULD'VE HAD ABU NAZIR
CRYING BY NOW.
TIME FOR MY LAST OPTION.
- OH, MY GOD,
WOODY, STOP.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
- SCREW THIS COURT CASE.
YOU'RE NOT GONNA STEAL
ANY MORE OF MY MONEY.
YOU GET UP
OR YOU GO DOWN!
THREE...TWO...
TWO AND A HALF...
ONE! WALK!
- [screams]
- OOPSIE.
OKAY, STEVE!
NOW I BELIEVE YOU!
- [grunting]
[bones cracking]
I'M STILL ALIVE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE
I'M STILL ALI--WAIT.
WELL, I'LL BE DAMNED.
$2 OFF A SUBWAY FOOTLONG!
OH, IT'S EXPIRED.
WELL, AT LEAST
I CAN WALK AGAIN.